Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Hi, With Dr. Marianne Trent about supporting aspiring psychologists, whether it's always necessary to have a master's in order
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。大家好，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，今天我们将探讨如何支持有志成为心理学家的人，以及是否一定要拥有硕士学位才能
to pursue and progress your career as an aspiring psychologist. And today is my attempt to help to answer one side of that debate, really. I am going to be joined in conversation, which you can watch if you'd like to, on the Good Thinking Psychological Services YouTube channel. But you don't have to, you can just listen through this very podcast that you might be listening to right now. I'm going to be joined by a lady who works for a master's course. And now I should say that I haven't been funded or, you know, cajoled in any way to record this episode. I reached out to the course because it was a course that I had studied and that I had found really useful. So yeah, just take on board what we discuss. We're discussing the benefits mainly of doing a master's. But if you would like to talk to the other side of this
追求并推进你的心理学职业生涯。今天我试图从一个角度来回答这个争论。我将进行一场对话，如果你愿意，可以在“Good Thinking Psychological Services”的 YouTube 频道上观看。当然，你也可以只通过你现在正在收听的这个播客来收听。我将邀请一位在硕士课程任教的女士加入。我需要说明的是，我没有接受任何资助，也没有受到任何人的怂恿来录制这期节目。我联系这个课程是因为我曾经学习过它，并觉得它非常有价值。所以，请参考我们讨论的内容。我们主要讨论攻读硕士学位的益处。但如果你想探讨这个问题的另一面，
argument that maybe you think you don't need a master's to progress your career in psychology, then do please drop into my DMs or send me an email and we can absolutely discuss getting you on to talk to the other side of this debate. And similarly, if you found it useful thinking from the perspective of a mother in last week's episode about whether you can, should and what it would be like to train as a professional psychologist when you're a mother. If you'd like to discuss it from a male perspective, do let me know as well. And I hope you'll find this episode really useful and it might open your eyes to thinking about different ways of strengthening your CV and I will look forward to catching up with you at the end of this episode. Yes, I hope you find it useful and speak to you very soon.
即你认为不需要硕士学位也能推进心理学职业生涯，请务必给我发私信或发送电子邮件，我们绝对可以讨论邀请你来探讨这个争论的另一面。同样，如果你觉得上周从母亲的角度探讨是否可以、应该以及作为一名母亲去接受专业心理学家培训是什么样的体验很有用，如果你想从男性的角度进行讨论，也请告诉我。希望你觉得这期节目非常有用，它可能会让你以不同的方式思考如何充实你的简历。我期待在节目结束时与你交流。是的，希望你觉得有用，我们很快再聊。
Welcome along to Dr Mel West who joins us from Newman. Hi Mel. Hi thank you very much for having me. Thank you. I reached out to your predecessor who was Lorna because I had done the master's qualification with Newman and so when I was wanting to talk about masters you know sometimes it's better the devil you know um but I understand that you took over after Lorna is that right? That's right yes so I took over from the running the masters in 2017 it was a big thing because um Lorna set the course up and she'd been running it for a long time uh and so some big shoes to fill but I think I'm doing all right yeah. hard to give away your babies isn't it absolutely that's the thing as well yes
欢迎来自纽曼大学（Newman）的梅尔·韦斯特博士（Dr. Mel West）。你好，梅尔。你好，非常感谢邀请我。谢谢。我联系了你的前任洛娜（Lorna），因为我曾在纽曼大学修读过硕士学位，所以当我想谈论硕士学位时，你知道，有时还是“熟悉的魔鬼”更好。但我了解到你是接替洛娜工作的，对吗？是的，没错。我是从2017年开始接手硕士课程管理的。这是一件大事，因为洛娜创立了这个课程，并且已经运营了很长时间，所以这是一个很难填补的空缺，但我认为我做得还不错。要把自己的“孩子”交出去很难，不是吗？绝对是这样，确实如此。
I think she was quite watchful over it for a while but I think I've sort of earned the trust now um and yes she obviously an absolute fountain of knowledge with so much to give having set it up um you know as a novel course and having set that up and being part of the initial thought about developing it she's given me so much information that yeah it's um enabled me to to go into it feeling quite confident um and running it successfully yeah brilliant we will hear a little bit about the novel way that your particular course is set up a little bit later but our audience is not just clinical psychologists like me our audience can be anyone really who is an aspiring psychologist or working in various different areas of psychology could
我想她有一段时间对课程非常关注，但我认为我已经赢得了她的信任。她显然是一个知识宝库，在创立这个课程并参与最初的开发构想后，她给予了我很多信息，这使我能够充满信心地接手并成功运营它。太棒了。我们稍后会详细了解你们课程独特的设置方式。但我们的听众不仅仅像我这样的临床心理学家，我们的听众可以是任何有志成为心理学家的人，或者在心理学各个领域工作的人。你能告诉我们一些关于你的心理学职业生涯，以及你是如何走到今天这一步的吗，梅尔？
you tell us a little bit about your kind of psychology career and how you got to be where you are now please Mel. Certainly yeah so I finished my undergraduate degree and I actually didn't go straight into a master's I decided that I'd had enough and of education higher education and I needed a break and I went into finance because obviously psychology allows that with all the stats um and I have many years of working in finance and got married and had children and then we moved to a different part of the country I'd always felt I wanted to go back to it wasn't finished with psychology um but obviously once you get caught up in life it can be difficult uh so I but having moved to a different uh part of the country I'd sort of given up my job and I felt free to try something new.
当然可以。我本科毕业后并没有直接攻读硕士学位。我当时觉得我已经受够了高等教育，需要休息一下，于是进入了金融行业，因为心理学背景在统计学方面很有帮助。我在金融行业工作了很多年，结婚生子，然后我们搬到了国家的另一个地方。我一直觉得我想回去，我还没有完成心理学学业，但显然一旦你陷入生活琐事，这可能会很困难。但在搬到国家的另一个地方后，我辞去了工作，感到可以自由地尝试新事物。
So I went back to university and I actually because I had done back in those days, psychology with health studies, there wasn't health psychology back then. I had to do a PG certificate to get the conversion for the BPS graduate registration so I did that and then I went on and did my master's in health psychology and then did my PhD from that point I've been working in again higher education at different universities. Thank you so much. You know, thank you for chatting to me. We were chatting just before we went live about actually quite how unique the qualification certainly was when I was looking for it in 2006, 2007. Because when I was doing it, it was part-time distance learning in the main, but I had to kind of go a little bit in once a term for teaching and for an exam but I understand it's moved and become even more modern.
所以我回到了大学。因为我当时修读的是心理学与健康研究，那时还没有健康心理学。我必须修读一个研究生证书（PG Certificate）来获得英国心理学会（BPS）的研究生注册资格，所以我完成了那个课程，然后继续攻读了健康心理学硕士学位，接着攻读了博士学位。从那时起，我一直从事高等教育工作，在不同的大学任教。非常感谢。谢谢你与我交谈。我们在直播前还在聊，当我2006年、2007年寻找这个资格认证时，它是多么独特。因为我当时修读时，主要是非全日制远程学习，但我每学期必须去学校参加教学和考试，但我了解到它现在已经变得更加现代化了。
It has that's right yes we are now completely online apart from one day you come in for the induction day and that's where we talk you through you know make sure you can use the library systems make sure you can use Moodle and so you can navigate your way around the the sort of electronic sort of versions of everything and also that just enables you to meet your cohort in person and the stuff and then it's all online there are are no exams. It's just coursework. And like I said, we we are doing recorded lectures so that they're available. And then we have the chat functions where we discuss the reading and there are sort of online activities and quizzes and things. So, yeah, it's amazing how everything is done electronically yeah and I guess the pandemic has sped up that process as well absolutely yeah so obviously we
确实如此。我们现在完全在线，除了入学第一天需要到校一次。在那天，我们会指导你确保你能使用图书馆系统，确保你能使用 Moodle，这样你就可以浏览所有电子版资料。这也让你有机会亲自见到你的同学。之后一切都在线进行，没有考试，只有课程作业。正如我所说，我们提供录制的讲座，以便随时观看。我们还有聊天功能来讨论阅读材料，以及在线活动和测验等。所以，一切都通过电子方式完成，这真是太神奇了。我想疫情也加速了这个过程。
were moving towards that sort of gradually um the world generally but uh yes as the as the course was already um mostly online at that point uh it was you know um it was it was still quite novel in in that respect at that time and covid's pushed it forward and i said so now we are making it even more online and even more interactive online that's that that's the difference i'd say that's the thing before it was less it was more asynchronous and now it's becoming more synchronous because we're much more au fait if you like with doing these face-to-face sort of you know digital electronic kind of contacts which is great because we then are getting to see the students rather than see a picture of the students all the
绝对是这样。我们当时确实在逐渐向那个方向发展，整个世界也是如此。但由于该课程当时已经大部分在线，在那个时候这确实非常新颖。新冠疫情推动了这一进程，正如我所说，现在我们让它变得更加在线化、更加互动。这就是区别。以前它更多是异步的，现在变得更加同步，因为我们对进行这种面对面的数字电子联系更加熟悉了。这很棒，因为我们现在能看到学生，而不是一直只看到他们的照片。
time you guys were like 13 14 years ahead of the you know the remote working curve you you're really doing good stuff um a really common question i'm asked um all the time really um which is uh do i need a master's know, to progress my career in psychology, either clin psych, or health or forensic, you know, do I need that? Or can I do that without? And I guess that's an important kind of one for us to weigh up together. Yes, definitely is very important. I don't, I think that some people can be lucky, and you could get away without having a master's um and i think like we've said um we mentioned before briefly before we came on air that um maybe you could if there was this belief that if you had a first you could get away without doing a master's but actually i think um
你们领先于远程工作趋势大约13到14年，你们真的做得很好。我经常被问到一个非常普遍的问题，那就是：我需要硕士学位来推进我的心理学职业生涯吗？无论是临床心理学、健康心理学还是法医心理学，我需要它吗？还是没有它也能做到？我想这是一个我们一起权衡的重要问题。是的，这绝对非常重要。我不认为，我认为有些人可能很幸运，没有硕士学位也能过关。正如我们之前在直播前简要提到的，也许如果你有本科一等学位，你可能不需要硕士学位。但实际上，我认为
it's they're so competitive the field of psychology is so competitive that actually even if you have a first uh a master's is a real benefit um because it is a step up from an undergrad even if you have got a uh first it is a higher level you know we talk about them uh in universities we talk about it yeah your first is year four, and then second year is level five, third year is level six, and then your master's is level seven. And that is a step up when you look at all the marking criteria, there's a little bit more expected. And I think that maybe employers are aware of that, and certainly within within psychology there's an awareness of that so I think you don't always need a master's you could be lucky but it's mostly advantageous. Yeah I guess what I liked about what I did and I'd said before we came on as well
心理学领域竞争非常激烈，即使你有一等学位，硕士学位也是一个真正的优势。因为它比本科高出一个台阶。即使你有一等学位，它也是一个更高的水平。在大学里，我们谈论它时，你的本科一年级是4级，二年级是5级，三年级是6级，而硕士是7级。当你查看所有的评分标准时，它确实有更高的期望。我认为雇主们可能意识到了这一点，在心理学领域内肯定有这种意识。所以我认为你不一定总是需要硕士学位，你可能会很幸运，但它通常是有利的。是的，我想我喜欢我所做的事情，正如我之前所说，
people would be like I'd rather listen to what you were speaking about before it sounds good but before we came on I only did I think the postgraduate certificate because I managed to get on the doctorate after one year um and that was still really advantageous actually so I was really pleased I was still able to get a qualification for that one year but even just the rigorous way that you taught me about research and being able to comfortably take that apart pick it apart put it back together and construct my own was really useful yes yes that's right so um it's the case that it is we often have students starting they have to register for the masters anyway that's the way it kind of works at the moment um but they sort of leave after doing the first year which is three taught modules and that gives you a postgraduate
人们会说我宁愿听你之前讲的内容，听起来不错。但在我们开始之前，我只修读了研究生证书，因为我在一年后就成功申请到了博士学位。这实际上仍然非常有优势。我很高兴我能在那一年获得一个资格证书。但即使只是你们教给我的关于研究的严谨方式，以及能够从容地拆解、分析、重组并构建我自己的研究，也非常有用。是的，没错。通常有学生开始时必须注册硕士学位，这是目前的运作方式，但他们在完成第一年（即三个授课模块）后就离开了，这会给你一个研究生证书。或者你可以继续留下来，完成六个授课模块，获得研究生文凭。通常，正如我所说，学生开始时认为他们会完成整个硕士学位，然后正如你所说，你申请了临床博士学位，尝试了一下，然后获得了名额，所以他们就拿了较低的学位。但他们总是说，研究方法的第一模块确实对面试有帮助，因为面试中你需要做测试，谈论研究，谈论你感兴趣的内容以及你将如何开展研究。它就是这样设计的，课程旨在帮助解决这些问题。而且正如你所说，它不仅仅是关于
certificate or you can stay on and you might finish the the six taught modules which is the postgraduate diploma and often like I say students will start thinking they're going to finish the whole masters and then as you said you did apply thinking I'll just give it a chance the clinical doctor I'll try it and then they get a place awarded a place and so then they take the lesser award and but they always say yeah that first module in research methods really does help with that interview where you have to do tests and you have to talk about you know research and and how what kind of things are of interest and how you would go about carrying out research it's and it is designed that way that's the course is designed so that it will help with those kind of things and obviously like you said it's not
临床心理学，它适用于你进入的任何工作领域、任何职业。如果你想领导事务，特别是在应用环境中，进行行动研究（Action Research）真的很有帮助。你可能不需要正式的研究项目，但你可以进行行动研究，即在实际环境中边做边研究。这真的有助于提供证据，证明在任何工作中都需要做出改变。谢谢。显然，任何硕士学位的主要缺点之一是，它可能意味着你必须减少工作或带薪工作。在传统的授课型硕士课程中，你可能无法在课程之外做任何工作，或者你可能选择不工作，以便专注于硕士学位。当然，硕士学习有财务影响，因为你还必须支付学费。所以这些东西不是免费的，当我们试图考虑劳动力的包容性和多样性时，这可能真的很棘手。现在还有其他补贴或助学金方式来获取硕士资助吗？或者奖学金之类的？
just about uh clinical psychology here it's about and it just it can help with any area of of work that you're going in any career if you want to be leading things and um especially in sort of an applied kind of setting where things might really help to do action research you might not need a formal kind of uh research project but you can do action research which is research as you go through in a real setting uh and that can really help to give you evidence of making a change that is required in any work actually. Thank you. Obviously one of the main drawbacks for any masters is that it might mean that you have to you know do less work or paid work I mean or you know in
我想有些大学确实提供一些，这取决于查看大学提供什么。因为显然大多数学生都在寻求通过学生贷款来完成学业。
traditionally taught masters you might not be able to do any work around it you know or you might choose not to so you can really focus on your masters and of course there are financial implications to master's study in that you have to pay tuition fees as well so it's not you know this stuff doesn't come for free and that can be really tricky when we're trying to to think about inclusion and diversity in our workforce as well are there any other subsidized or bursary ways for accessing master's funding or you know scholarships anything like that these days I think um I think some universities do offer some it's a case of looking at what uh universities have on offer because obviously most students are looking to go through student finance
并不是所有的硕士学位费用都一样，这与本科生不同。大多数本科生每年的学费是9500英镑。我认为这因人而异。你可能非常幸运，能找到公司赞助你。有时在职人员确实能从雇主那里获得支持，并支付学费。但这是一个问题。正如你所说，大多数人必须有工作经验，而工作经验的报酬并不高。试图在工作与要求极高的硕士课程之间取得平衡，是一种需要培养的技能。是的，我认为这是一个非常好的主意，我之前没考虑过，但你确实可以潜在地要求雇主提供帮助。但即使你是在进行远程学习，
and not all masters cost the same amount of money which isn't the same as undergraduates most undergraduates cost nine and a half thousand a year for studying and I think that yeah it's individual you could you could also be really lucky and get a company to sponsor you and sometimes people in the work situation do actually manage to get support from their from their employer and get the tuition fees paid but yeah it is a problem and like you say most of you have to have uh work experience the work experience isn't well paid and trying to then balance that with your very demanding masters is quite a sort of a balancing act and quite a skill that you need to develop really yeah I think that's a really good idea not one that I considered of but you could you could potentially ask your employer to help with that but certainly even if you're doing distance learning
像我当时那样，如果你的雇主愿意偶尔给你一点学习假，或者允许你在较安静的时候处理作业，那真的很有帮助。因为这真的很棘手。当我还在读硕士时，我遭遇了车祸，经历了分手，我还在努力争取新的助理职位。在我的生活中，这并不是一段轻松的时光，同时还要学习这些东西，并保持在带薪工作中的职能。你知道，我们对有志成为心理学家的人要求很高，不是吗？是的，确实如此。大多数学生来到我们这里时，通常是在20多岁，这是一个充满变化的时期，有很多事情
like I was it can be really helpful if your employer is on board with giving you a little bit of study leave here and then or allowing you to work on assignments, you know, in quieter moments, you know, because it is really tricky. You know, when I was when I was with you, I had a car crash, I had a breakup, you know, I was trying to strive for new assistant posts. And, you know, it's not an easy time in my life whilst also trying to learn this stuff and get it in my head and be functional in my paid work as well. You know, we are asking a lot of our aspiring psychologists, aren't we? Yes, we really are it is um it's a most i suppose uh students are coming to us at a time you know usually in their 20s when it's there's a lot of change and there's a lot
需要掌握，而且你还在作为一个个体不断发展，所以这是一个要求非常高的时期。有很多事情需要平衡和兼顾。但令人惊奇的是，它是可以实现的。我认为如果你有决心，并且动力十足，你就能做到并取得成功。但这确实有很多需要处理的事情，特别是当你还有财务问题时。这非常困难。是的，确实如此。我想我当时在生活中那段棘手的时期，确实是靠着坚韧的毅力在支撑。但我觉得我们思考如何
to get to grips with and you're still developing as a person so it is a very demanding time um and yet there's a lot to to be balancing and juggling. But it's amazing how it can be pulled off. I think if you're determined and you're very well motivated, you can pull it off and you can succeed. But it is a lot to deal with, especially when you've got the finance issues as well. It's very difficult. Yes, it certainly is and uh yeah I think I was just operating on grim and gritty determination really at times during that tricky patch in my life but you know it's not I think it's important that we think about how we
平衡并降低倦怠风险很重要。对于硕士生、潜在的硕士生，甚至那些没有考虑攻读硕士学位的人，你有什么建议来减少和避免心理健康职业中的倦怠吗？是的，绝对有。我们实际上在我负责的第二年模块中对此进行了很多讨论，这是一个非常重要的主题。在任何类型的治疗中，这都是一个非常付出的职业。它会消耗你很多精力，可能会让人精疲力竭。然而，我们向客户推荐所有这些建议，却不花时间对自己做同样的事情，不给自己留出空间。而且由于竞争如此激烈，你经常会发现它在工作场所滋生了更多的竞争。
balance and reduce the risk of burnout is there any guidance you'd give to master's students or potential master's students or even people that aren't considering master's for how to reduce and avoid burnout in mental health professions um yes definitely uh we cover that quite a lot on one of the second year modules actually that i run um it's a really important topic. And it's, you know, there's lots of sort of work looking into how as a profession, when in any type of therapy, it's it's a very giving profession. It takes a lot out of you. It can be quite exhausting. And yet we sort of recommend all these things to clients and yet don't take the time to do it to us and give ourselves that room. And because it's so competitive, you often find that it's breeding more competition in the workplace.
那么谁先进入？谁的工作量最大？谁的客户最多？这并不健康。所以我们真的鼓励人们反思。反思是成为心理学家的重要组成部分。你应该能够花时间反思正在发生的事情。你的感觉如何？你如何能让事情变得更好一点？我试图在压力积累之前识别出任何压力迹象，因为压力可能会慢慢积累并悄悄袭来，直到你功能失调时，你才会意识到它对你的影响有多大。所以，真的要鼓励留出时间进行自我保健，找到有助于自我保健的事情，确保将其安排进去，并推掉工作，
So who gets in first? Who's got the heaviest workload? Who's got the most clients? And it's not very healthy. And so we really encourage people to to reflect. Reflection is a massive part of being a psychologist. You should be able to spend time and just reflect on what's happening. How do you feel? How can you make things a bit better? I'm trying to recognise any signs of stress before it builds up because stress can build up and come upon you quite slowly and it's not until you're sort of dysfunctional that you realise how much it has affected you. So really encouraging time for self-care and finding things that help with self-care and making sure you fit it in and pushing work back
不要承担更多任务，并尽量不要被卷入成为心理学家那种竞争激烈的元素中。这确实很棘手，不是吗？我记得当我担任助理心理学家时，人们要求你做各种事情，有一种期望是你必须去做，但你已经有太多其他事情了。我当时为我的助理工作在三个住院病房工作，这是一项艰巨的工作，我热爱它，但这种关系很棘手，你觉得你想说“是”，你觉得你必须说“是”，但你一天中并没有足够的时间。是的，绝对是这样。显然，这通常被卖给那些低薪工作的人，作为
and not taking on more and trying not to get it to be pulled into that very competitive element of being a psychologist. It is tricky isn't it, I remember when I was working as an assistant psychologist and you know you're asked to do stuff and there is that expectation that you will just do it but you've already got so many other things I was working on three inpatient wards for my qualified for my assistant work it's a big job and I loved it but there is that kind of you know it's it's a it's a tricky relationship where you feel like you want to say yes and you kind of have to say yes but you don't really have enough hours in the day yes absolutely so um obviously that's it's often sold to those in lower paid jobs as
对你来说是很好的经验，你为什么要拒绝呢？是的，这确实是很好的经验，但你应该被分配正确的时间框架，将这些工作纳入工作量中，让你感到自己是在全力以赴，而不是被分散得太薄，以至于无法完全专注于任何事情。所以我认为关键在于设定界限。无论你多么感激能担任这个角色，这是学生们经常向我表达的一种感觉。他们感激能拥有这个角色，但如果他们不配，他们就不会得到那个角色。所以关键在于欣赏你的价值，并设定任何界限，
it's good experience for you why would you say no uh and yes it is good experience but you should be allocated the right time uh sort of frames to fit these in it within a uh within the workload that allows you to to feel that you're giving it everything rather than being spread so thinly you you aren't able to fully be present with anything. So I'd say it's about being boundaried. You have to, however much you're grateful for being in the role, and that's often a feeling which students sort of relay to me. They're grateful for having the role, but they wouldn't be getting that role if they weren't deserving of it. So it's about appreciating your value and putting any boundaries
并表明并说明你想要经验，你非常感激这些经验，但你需要对你实际能做的事情保持现实。是的，这很可能也是你申请中的一个问题。你知道，你什么时候能够对事情说“不”？所以尝试并实践这一点是一个很好的练习。这非常重要，我们必须能够了解自己的极限，并自信地保护它们。否则，我们将被分散得太薄，这会导致倦怠，会导致长期的病假，甚至可能导致我们想要离开
in place and and showing and saying that you want yes you want the experience you're very grateful to the experience but you need to be realistic about what you can actually do yeah and that is likely to be a question on your on your applications as well you know when have you been able to say no to stuff um so it's good practice to try and put that in you know to try and give that a bash as well um you know it's very important that we're able to know our own limits and be confidently able to protect them um otherwise we will be too thinly spread and you know it will lead to burnout it will lead to long periods of sickness absence so absence and it might well lead to us wanting to leave
这个职业。而这根本不是任何人希望看到的。不，完全正确。所以，我们经常看到倦怠导致越来越多的缺勤和人们离开这个职业。他们说，实际上，进入这个职业的年轻人更容易受到倦怠的影响，这是因为他们太努力了。当然，积累经验对你更好，你会为工作带来更多价值，但如果你在达到那个点之前就离开了，那真的很令人难过，这对职业是有害的。所以，是的，我认为采取你能采取的措施并尝试设定界限非常重要。
the profession altogether. And that's just not what anyone wants for us. No, that's exactly right. So, you know, we see all the time where burnout is sort of leading to more and more absences and people leaving the profession. And they say that actually, you know, people, young people coming into the profession are more at risk of burnout and that's because they're trying so hard and and you don't get that experience of course it's better for you to build up experience and then you're bringing more to the job but if you're leaving before you get to that point that's really sad and it's detrimental for the profession. So, yeah, I think it is very it's very important to take what you can and try to be boundary.
正如你所说，这会有回报。你会被问到这个问题。能够说“不”是一种值得骄傲的能力。是的，我试图利用这个播客在心理学界传播一点同情心，并真正强调这不是一场比赛。我经常说，你今年、明年还是后年进入培训并不重要。这可能对个人很重要，如果你觉得自己在搁置生活，那可能很重要。但就最终成果而言，更好的是你在课程的第一天就进入状态，而不是感到不知所措，觉得一切都太多了，无法兼顾个人生活、专业工作和研究部分。
And like you said, it will pay. You will be asked about that. And it is something to to be proud of that you have that ability to say no. Yeah, I tried to use this podcast to spread a little bit of compassion in the psychology world as well and just to really highlight that this isn't a race you know I often say it doesn't really matter you know whether you get onto training this year or next year or the year after it might matter personally you know it might matter if you feel like you're putting your life on hold but in terms of the finished product you, what is actually better is that you get there on day one of your course and things feel within floundering and feeling like it's all too much they can't do the personal can't do the professional bit can't do the research bit because
因为当你进行任何专业心理学培训时，社交、兼顾生活确实有很多事情。所以，放慢脚步，确保你真正巩固了这些技能，给自己机会去学习研究、做研究，这意味着当你到达你选择的心理学专业资格路线时，你会感觉一切都在你的掌控之中。那要好得多。是的，绝对是这样。所以我经常听到这种情况。学生们感到非常沮丧，因为他们可以在四年内完成课程。所以显然，有些人年复一年地申请，他们感到非常沮丧。
it is you know that you and mixing socially with the cohort and juggling your life it is a lot isn't it when you're undergoing any professional psychology training and so some of the advantage of just slowing things down a bit and really making sure you're consolidating these skills, you're giving yourself opportunities to learn research, to do research, means that when you get to your chosen professional qualification route in psychology, it will feel like it's in your stride. And that is so much better. Yes, absolutely. Yes. So I hear that quite a lot. Students feel really disheartened because they can do the course over four years. So obviously, you know, some of them less are applying year after year and they're so disheartened.
我经常听到“我觉得我的生活被搁置了，我只想完成这个”。但正如我所说，关键在于尝试在脑海中稍微重构一下，思考“每一年我都更有经验，我将带来更多东西，我将能够更舒适地应对，并能够享受它”。这听起来可能很奇怪，但实际上，如果你能享受它，它将是一种更愉快的体验，你不太可能感到非常不知所措。所以，是的，关键在于接受你当时的各种能力，并知道无论你多么想要它，你最终可能会到达那里，或者你会到达某个地方，你会感到快乐。事情往往会朝着最好的方向发展。我认为缓慢的积累可能比
And often I hear I feel like my life's on hold and I just want to get this. But like I say, it's about trying to to frame it reframe it in your mind slightly and think about well each year I'm more experienced I'm going to be bringing more to it I'm going to be able to be more comfortable in it and be able to enjoy it and it seems like a bizarre thing to say but um actually if you can enjoy it um it's you it will be so much more pleasurable as an experience and you're less likely to feel really overwhelmed. So, yes, it's about sort of accepting your capabilities at the time and then knowing that however hard you sort of want, however much you want it it's okay you will if you will get there eventually probably um or you'll get to somewhere and you'll be happy things often work out for the best uh and yeah i think it's it's a slow build-up is probably more beneficial than
进入一个让你感到不知所措、感到恐慌且不舒服的状态更有益。所以你想要有一点挑战，但它必须是一种舒适的推动，而不是被大规模地淹没。是的，我想我把它比作我参加数学 GCSE 考试的时候。在10年级，我参加了一次考试，我发现它相当棘手。所以我真的花时间研究了我发现棘手的地方。我每周一次在午餐时间向我的数学老师寻求额外的帮助，因为我就是那种女孩。真的，当我的 GCSE 最终考试到来时，我走出考场，因为我看了每一个问题，心想“我能做那个，
going in way of feeling way over your head and then sort of feeling a bit panicky and and not comfortable so you want to have a little bit of a challenge but it's got to be a comfortable sort of push not being massively overwhelmed yeah I guess I kind of liken it to when I did my um my maths GCSE and in year 10 I did an exam um and I just found it quite tricky you know and so I really spent time looking at what I'd found tricky about that. And I asked my maths teacher for some additional help at lunchtimes, you know, once a week, because I was that kind of girl. And really, by the time my GCSE exam, final exam came, I walked out of that exam, because I'd looked at every question when I can do that,
我能做那个，我能做那个，我能做那个”。我走出考场时感觉自己绝对已经尽了全力。这和我参加博士面试时的感觉很像，他们问我问题。即使它们有点出乎意料，我仍然觉得我可以给出一个好的答案。我认为这就是区别。这就是时间和巩固以及专注的注意力可以非常有用的地方。绝对是这样。这就是它的缩影，不是吗？你积累了那种经验，你在生活各个方面拥有的经验越多，你带给面试或工作角色的东西就越多。这不仅对你以及你在该角色中的表现有益，
I can do that, I can do that, I can do that. I walked out feeling like I'd absolutely given it my best shot. And that's kind of how it felt when I was doing my doctorate interviews, is that they asked me questions. And even if they're a bit left field, I still felt like I could give a good answer. And I think that's the difference. That's what time and consolidation and kind of focused attention can be can be really useful for absolutely yeah so that's it it's like that's the that's the sort of epitome of it isn't it you sort of building up that experience and the more you experience you have in all aspects of your life the more you're bringing to that interview or job role and that's going to be beneficial not just for you and and how you perform as a
而且对你拥有的任何客户也有益。你将能够带来更多东西，因为你有更广泛的经验。所以，是的，我认为这完全正确。关键在于意识到所有的经验对你来说都是好的。他们说“如果它杀不死你，它会让你更强大”，这可能有点争议，但这意味着你有更多的东西可以提供，这对客户来说真的很好。是的，我们绝对不想暗示这一点。不，不，抱歉。不，我完全明白你的意思。
professional in that role but also to any clients that you have you're going to be able to bring more to it because you are sort of have a much wider sort of experience and more to bring to it so so yeah I think that's exactly right it is about just being aware that it's all experiences are good to you and they they say don't know if it doesn't kill you it makes you stronger which is a bit of a you know maybe a little bit controversial but it does mean that you have more to offer and that can be really good for clients. Yeah, we definitely don't want to be suggesting that. No, no, sorry. No, I absolutely know what you mean.
你知道，这是一种能够重构你思维的能力。当我攻读博士学位时，即使有关于那些在经历中留下伤疤的人的教学。这是一种感觉，只有当你幸存下来时，你才会留下伤疤。这是一个非常有力的想法。所以基本上，如果它杀不死你，那么你知道那是一件好事。但关键在于你之后如何谈论它，不是吗？即使在困难的面试中，具有挑战性的面试中，他们通常也会想知道你在逆境中是如何应对的，你是如何经历这一切的。我们需要在这方面练习有素，并证明经历过逆境是可以的。你知道，你想要
You know, it's being able to reframe your think when I was studying my doctorate, even there was teachings that we'd had about, about people that had been scarred as part of their experiences. And it's that sense of, you only get a scar if you've survived. And that's really powerful as an idea. So it is basically that if it doesn't kill you then you know that's a good thing um but it's how you then speak about that isn't it and even within difficult interviews um challenging interviews they will often want to know how you've coped in adversity and how you've gone through that and we need to be well practiced in doing that and also demonstrating that it's okay to have had adversity you know you want we
我们在心理学中需要全面发展的人，我们绝对不想要机器。不，完全正确。所以，这又回到了反思，不是吗？我之前提到了反思的重要性。这是心理学专业中的一个关键功能。关键在于思考那个事件对你意味着什么，你所经历的逆境，我们都有过。正如我们所说，在逆境中幸存下来并走出来，思考这意味着什么，以及你如何将其向前推进，你如何以积极的眼光利用它，这很重要。这显然会使你的客户受益，因为你可以与事物产生共鸣，你可以更多地谈论经验。
want well-rounded people in psychology we definitely don't want machines no that's exactly right yeah so it is about well it comes back to reflection doesn't it and i was saying the importance of reflection earlier um it's it is a key sort of function within a profession a psychology a professional um and you are it's about thinking about what that event meant to you that adversity that you've experienced and we all have um and it's you know like we say it's an important thing to survive um an adversity and to come out of it and think about what that means what it means um and how do you take it forward and what can you do with it in a positive light um and yeah that will obviously benefit clients you because you can relate to things and you can talk about experiences more
而且确实有更多的东西可以提供。绝对是这样。硕士课程通常还是在九月滚动开学吗？还是你可以在学年的不同时间点入学？我只是在想，人们现在正在听这个，他们想知道现在是时候了吗？我应该现在申请，还是申请硕士学习的最佳时间或唯一时间是什么时候？我认为现在大学正在尝试采取这种更灵活的申请和入学方式。但在我自己的经验中，我不知道目前有任何课程是在九月以外的时间开始的。我们只在九月开始。硕士申请与本科生不同。你知道，本科生确实是在前一年申请的。但对于硕士，你甚至可以在七月申请，
um and yeah just that more to offer really definitely um are masters generally still kind of roll on roll off in september or can you kind of roll on at different points of the academic year just i'm thinking people are listening to this now they're thinking is now the time you know do i apply now or when is the best time or the only time to apply for master's study? I think now universities are trying to get this sort of much more flexible approach to applying and starting. But in my own experience, I'm not aware of any that are currently actually starting other than in September. We start only in September. And applications for Masters, they're not the same as for undergraduates. You know, in undergraduates, you're applying the year before, really. But for Masters, you can still be applying in July
并期望在九月开始。所以你可以好好考虑一下。另外，我只想说，无论如何提交一份申请都是值得的。你提交一份申请，然后你可以考虑是否真的想开始。通常你可以推迟入学。但我认为，由于硕士课程的结构是模块按特定顺序在特定时间教授的，所以它并不总是像在不同时间开始那样灵活。也许这就是下一个“新颖的滚动式硕士课程”，你知道，当你准备好时就来这里。实际申请的流程是什么？是表格还是面试？通常的申请途径是什么？
and be expecting to start in September. So you can have a good long think about it also I would just say that it's probably worth putting in an application anyway you know just put in an application and you can think about whether or not you do want to start often you can defer your start but yeah I think because of the way masters are structured with modules taught in a certain order at a certain time that it's not always as flexible as being able to start at different times maybe that's next for the the sort of novel yes roll on roll off masters you know here when you're ready and what's the deal with actual applications is that like a form is an interview? What tends to be the application route?
嗯，不同的大学做不同的事情。对我们来说，这只是一个表格。我们只有一个表格。没那么多。而且我想说，实际上，当你写个人陈述时，我们并不总是想读到这是你一直想做的事情。所以当人们坦诚相待，说他们工作努力、动力十足时，这很好。这就足够了。我们不需要几页纸来证明你一直想做这件事，以及证明情况如何。只要说你现在真的想做这件事，并且动力十足就足够了。哦，你让我回想起了我的本科个人陈述，老实说，我不久前找到了它的副本，它太糟糕了。它谈论的事情就像“哦，我和我哥哥相处得很好”，为什么那会在里面？那对我有什么帮助？我是怎么进入课程的？我现在更擅长写个人陈述了，
Well, different universities do different things. For us, it's just a form. We just have a form. It's not that much. And I would say, actually, when you're writing your personal statement, we don't we don't always want to read that this is all you've ever wanted to do and so it's nice when people are just open and honest and say you know that they're hard working and well motivated and that's enough we don't need pages and pages of that you've always wanted to do it and how and demonstrating how this is the case um it's enough to just say that you really want to do this now and you're really well motivated oh you just made me flash back to my um my undergraduate uh personal statement and honestly I found a copy of it not so long ago it was dreadful it was like talking about stuff like oh me and my brother get on quite well like why was that in there who was not helping me how did I get on to a course I'm now much better at writing personal statements
但老实说，所以是的，思考什么应该和不应该出现在你的个人陈述中非常有趣。是的，绝对是这样。有时读到它们确实很有趣。我想大多数人回首往事时都会想“哦”。但我认为有时一两句话，或者一段半的内容就足够说明问题了。是的，关键在于使其直接相关，这实际上是所有学术写作的关键。非常可爱。非常感谢你加入我，梅尔。有什么我没问你，或者你想谈论但我们还没谈到的吗？没有了，真的没有。只是我们谈到了包容性和多样性，以及这在心理学领域总体上有多么重要。
but honestly so yeah it's very interesting to think about what should and should not be in your personal statement yes absolutely yes uh It is funny sometimes reading them. And I think most people will look back and sort of think, oh. But I think sometimes there's a couple of sentences, well, a paragraph and a half maybe says more than enough. And yes, it's about making it directly relevant, which is all of it. That's a key to all academic writing really lovely um thank you so much for joining me mel is there anything that we i haven't asked you or that you wanted to talk about that we haven't done so far um not really no just um we're talking about sort of inclusivity uh and diversity and just how that's really
这是一个非常重要的点。希望障碍正在消除，我们正在让它变得更好。但我认为这只是我们需要承认的事情。我认为我们所有人都承认这一点很重要。绝对是这样。我们播客中还有更多关于包容性、多样性和平等的内容。但非常感谢你加入我，与你交流真是太好了。祝你度过一个愉快的夏天。如果将来我能提供任何帮助，请告诉我。那太好了，谢谢。非常感谢。感谢你的收听。也非常感谢我们的嘉宾，梅尔·韦斯特博士。我觉得这真的、真的很有趣。
important to make that much uh much better within psychology generally that's a that's a really important point and hopefully um yeah the barriers are coming down and we're making it better but that's just something to just acknowledge i think it's important that we all acknowledge that um definitely that's all we've got more coming up in the podcast about inclusion and diversity and equality as well but thank you so much for joining me it's been so lovely um connecting with you um and just wishing you a lovely summer um yeah and let me know if I can help with anything in future that's lovely thank. Thank you very much. Thanks for having me. Thank you so much for listening. And thank you so much to our guest, Dr. Mel West. I have found it really, really interesting.
在心理学领域内将其做得更好非常重要，这是一个非常关键的观点。希望障碍正在消除，我们正在改善这一现状，但我认为我们都应该承认这一点。当然，我们播客后续还会讨论包容性、多样性和平等问题。非常感谢您的加入，与您交流非常愉快，祝您度过一个美好的夏天。如果未来有什么我可以帮忙的，请随时告诉我。太好了，谢谢。非常感谢。谢谢邀请。非常感谢大家的收听。也要非常感谢我们的嘉宾梅尔·韦斯特博士。我觉得这次访谈真的非常非常有意思。
And like I said at the beginning, if you'd like to talk to the other side of this debate, if you think there are other ways to strengthen your CV without needing to do a master's, then do let me know. And we can also talk about that. If you've got any other ideas for podcast episode content, do let me know. And we also, as a little sneak scoop, we've got an exclusive episode coming where I answer any questions for you. It's going to be an Ask Marianne anything special. So if you have got any questions and you'd like to record yourself asking me them, then do let me know.
正如我在开头所说，如果你想讨论这场辩论的另一面，如果你认为还有其他方法可以在不需要硕士学位的情况下提升你的简历，请务必告诉我。我们也可以谈谈这一点。如果你对播客节目的内容有任何其他想法，也请告诉我。另外，作为一个小剧透，我们即将推出一期特别节目，我会回答你们提出的任何问题。这将是一期“玛丽安有问必答”特别节目。所以，如果你有任何问题，并且想录下你提问的声音，请务必告诉我。
And there's details for how you can record testimonials or questions in the show notes. You can listen to all back episodes of the podcast by checking them out on Spotify, on Amazon, on Apple Podcasts, and you can also listen to all of them on YouTube as well. And basically, I believe anywhere you could envisage or dream of accessing podcasts, you can reach us as well, which includes Google. And yeah, Deezer, I think there's one called Deezer. Yes, you can reach me there too. We've had a lovely, successful spring and summer in the Aspiring Psychologist membership. Lots of people within the membership have this year gained places onto clinical psychology courses. And they said that they found that the membership had really helped to support them and to help them perform optimally in the interviews. We've had a couple
关于如何录制感言或问题，详细信息可以在节目说明中找到。你可以通过 Spotify、Amazon、Apple Podcasts 收听播客的所有往期节目，也可以在 YouTube 上收听。基本上，我相信任何你能想到或梦寐以求的播客访问平台，你都能找到我们，包括 Google。还有 Deezer，我想有一个叫 Deezer 的平台。是的，你也可以在那里找到我。在“有抱负的心理学家”会员社区，我们度过了一个美好而成功的春夏季。今年，会员中有许多人成功进入了临床心理学课程。他们表示，会员社区确实为他们提供了支持，并帮助他们在面试中发挥出了最佳水平。我们有几位
of people who wish to carry on in the membership as well, even though they are going to be trainee clinical psychologists. So that is just the most wonderful feedback. though they are going to be trainee clinical psychologists so that is just the most wonderful feedback if you would like to rub shoulders not only with myself but with other aspiring psychologists and also other trainee clinical psychologists or maybe if you are a trainee psychologist and you would welcome some more support some more compassionate guidance and some more thinking about enhancing developing your personal professional and research skills then do get yourself onto the aspiring psychologist waiting list and we've got some exciting developments coming for you to be able to practice and improve your skills and your chances of being published as well in research
成员即使在成为临床心理学实习生后，也希望继续留在会员社区。这真是最棒的反馈。如果你不仅想与我交流，还想与其他有抱负的心理学家以及其他临床心理学实习生交流，或者如果你是一名实习心理学家，希望获得更多支持、更多富有同情心的指导，并更多地思考如何提升你的个人、专业和研究技能，那么请务必加入“有抱负的心理学家”候补名单。我们即将推出一些令人兴奋的发展项目，让你能够练习并提高你的技能，以及在研究中发表论文的机会
within the membership. You've got to be on the waiting list for when the space is next open on the 1st of July. So details of how to do that can be accessed via my link tree, which is available from all of my socials. Do come and connect with me on my socials. Basically, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent on pretty much everywhere. So I'm that on Twitter. I'm that on LinkedIn. I keep getting LinkedIn and link tree mixed up. I'm that on Instagram. I'm Marianne Trent on Facebook and also Good Thinking Psychological Services Facebook and YouTube Good Thinking Psychological Services so honestly if you haven't yet stumbled across me on social media I'm also on TikTok for Dr Marianne Trent too then I don't know how you've done it you know you must live in a social media, which is probably very good for your mental health.
在会员社区内。你必须在 7 月 1 日名额开放时进入候补名单。获取相关操作的详细信息可以通过我的 Linktree，它在我的所有社交媒体上都有提供。欢迎在社交媒体上与我联系。基本上，我在几乎所有平台上都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。我在 Twitter 上是这个名字，在 LinkedIn 上也是。我总是把 LinkedIn 和 Linktree 搞混。我在 Instagram 上也是这个名字。我在 Facebook 上是 Marianne Trent，还有 Good Thinking Psychological Services 的 Facebook 和 YouTube 账号。所以老实说，如果你还没在社交媒体上发现我——我在 TikTok 上也是 Dr Marianne Trent——那我不知道你是怎么做到的，你一定生活在社交媒体之外，这对你的心理健康可能非常有好处。
So long may that last. But yeah, we do some lovely stuff in the membership. And of course, there's the upcoming Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. know someone who is currently training on the Hull, the special Hull York scheme that takes you from undergraduate to the doctorate in clinical psychology. I'd love to be able to include a story from someone in that position within the upcoming Aspiring Psychologist membership. So if you know someone who fulfills that brief, then do let them know about me. And similarly, if you know someone or perhaps you are someone who has trained initially, perhaps done your undergraduate, maybe done your master's in a different country and then come across to the UK to pursue your professional qualification. Perhaps you've even got on to a professional qualifying course, but English wasn't your first language or you weren't born in the UK.
愿这种状态长久保持。但确实，我们在会员社区做了一些很棒的事情。当然，还有即将出版的《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书。如果你认识目前正在赫尔大学学习的人，参加那个从本科直接升读临床心理学博士的特殊赫尔-约克项目，我很乐意在即将出版的《有抱负的心理学家》一书中收录来自该职位人士的故事。所以，如果你认识符合这个条件的人，请务必让他们了解我。同样，如果你认识某人，或者你自己就是这样的人：最初在其他国家完成了本科或硕士学位，然后来到英国追求专业资格。也许你甚至已经进入了专业资格课程，但英语不是你的母语，或者你不是在英国出生的。
I'd love to be able to include a couple of stories from your perspective within the Aspiring Psychologist book too, which is hopefully going to be published at the start of October. Thank you so much for listening right to the end. Let me know if you've got any questions or if you'd like to record your question for me for the special Q&A episode. I'm going to drop in the Q&A jingle here just, you know, because I've got it. It's ready. I'm excited, you know I love a jingle, thank you so much for being part of my world, and take care of yourselves, be kind to you. ask her anything questions and answers
我很乐意在《有抱负的心理学家》一书中收录几个来自你视角的真实故事，这本书有望在 10 月初出版。非常感谢你一直听到最后。如果你有任何问题，或者想为特别问答节目录制你的问题，请告诉我。我打算在这里插入问答环节的叮当声，因为我有这个素材，而且已经准备好了。我很兴奋，你知道我喜欢叮当声。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，照顾好自己，善待自己。问她任何问题，问答环节
questions and answers questions and answers with Dr. Mary Trent If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the As the Clinical
问答环节，问答环节，与玛丽·特伦特博士一起。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是作为临床
Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家集体一书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我在做错什么，也减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。